The Blood-Brain Barrier is pretty much what
its name sounds like; a barrier that separates
your blood from your brain.
But what’s the point?
Doesn’t our brain want the sweet sweet nutrients
in our blood?
I like to think of your brain as a nightclub,
let's call it Club Head.
Inside it’s popping, there’s lights and
electronic music and the mood is good.
The circulatory system is like the street
outside the nightclub, and just anybody can
walk up to the club’s door via your bloodstream.
Conditions in your blood change dramatically
all the time, like after you eat or exercise,
but things need to be stable in your brain
to keep the party going.
So Club Head has a bouncer to keep the riff
raff out -- the blood-brain barrier.
The bouncer, in this case, are endothelial
cells.
These cells line the walls throughout your
whole vascular system, but in your brain the
gaps between them are extremely small, forming
what are called tight junctions.
These small gaps, along with a lack of pathways
through the endothelial cells, keeps your
blood and your brain separate.
Obviously, the brain is not totally isolated,
there has to be some interaction.
Your brain is connected to the circulatory
system because it needs the things floating
around in your blood to function, just like
any other cells in your body.
So the bouncer has to let some things into
the club…
Like the life of the party: Glucose!
Your brain uses glucose for energy, but glucose
can’t get through the endothelial cells
on its own…
It needs a friend to get past the bouncer.
So, special glucose transporters in endothelial
cells shuttle the valuable molecule through
the blood-brain barrier as quickly as possible
like it’s a VIP.
Some other molecules can sneak by the bouncer
when he’s not looking by using diffusion.
Water and gasses like CO2 and oxygen diffuse
through the endothelial cell’s membrane
and out the other side to reach the brain.
But some less desirables can also sneak into
Club Head, like drunks and smokers.
By that I mean ethanol and nicotine, which
can also find their way into your brain because
they’re fat soluble.
They’re actually so good at getting into
your brain that they’re totally extracted
from your blood on their first pass through.
So the bouncer isn’t perfect, but he usually
does a good job of keeping the really nasty
stuff out that would cause diseases and infections.
But if harmful things do find their way in,
that’s when the blood-brain barrier becomes
a problem.
In order to treat some diseases of the brain,
doctors need to get medication past the blood-brain
barrier.
But the BBB will have none of it, and the
medication can’t get into the brain to do
its job.
To torture the night club metaphor one last
time, it’s like Club Head is burning down
but the bouncer won’t let the fire department
in because they don’t meet the dress code.
Scientists have been building models of the
blood-brain barrier, to figure out how to
sneak the firefighters in.
Until recently, they’ve been using animal
cells but in September of 2017, after a decade
of research, scientists have unveiled a model
that uses human cells to accurately mimic
how our actual blood-brain barrier works.
Understanding how to bypass the barrier can
help us treat brain cancer and other neurological
diseases like Parkinson’s and dementia.
This new model is hugely significant and will
help speed up the development of drugs that
will save and improve lives.
You’re doing a great job up there, blood-brain
barrier bouncer.
We just need you to lighten up a little bit
sometimes, ok?
If you’re going to run a club, whether real
or a really over-extended science metaphor
-- you’ll need to manage your finances.
FreshBooks, is an online invoicing and accounting
software that lets you manage your finances
or finances for a business!
You can send clean and professional looking
invoices in about 30 seconds.
With literally 2 clicks you can set yourself
up to receive payments online.
You can even take pictures of receipts on
your phone using FreshBooks’ mobile apps.
This makes claiming your expenses a million
times easier.
For a 30-day unrestricted trial, go to FreshBooks.com
slash Seeker, and enter “Seeker” in the
“How You’ve Heard About Us” section.
If you like this video click that subscribe
button for more science.
Curious about your brain and how it works?
Trace fires off on neurons here.One last thing:
the BBB was first discovered when researchers
injected dye into the circulatory system and
noticed the brain and spinal cord didn’t
color-up.
And the reverse happened too, tipping them
off that something was stopping the dye.
Thanks for watching and I’ll see you next
time on Seeker!